so you're being turned down for one of
your spec scripts I had I had written a
spec script that thing I wrote in two
weeks it was it was a biopic and I was
really amped about it and my manager was
like it's not commercial it's not going
to sell and I sent it to these producers
and they were like they at the end of
the day said no and so I started
thinking it's just going to sit on a
hard drive somewhere and that sucks you
know and forget me what about all these
other guys that don't have producers and
managers to send their scripts to there
there's got to be some worthy scripts
out there and it always bugged me that
just the system of you know query
letters and it's it's it's a shitty
system it's not a fishing at the end of
the day so yeah I just started thinking
of an alternative well let's talk about
how crowd-sourced studios will work
what's your plan for it is there a
website there is crowd-sourced studios
com okay great and then how do people
submit their work sure so i'll keep you
for the broad strokes on what it is we
do because it's not just screenplays
it's not just writing briefly okay so we
say to screenwriters we have a script
competition send us your best low-budget
spec scripts and by low-budget I mean
think you know blue ruin blood simple it
follows any genre send us your best
low-budget spec scripts if you're not
repped we don't care all the better if
you don't live in LA we don't care great
all that yeah so just send us your best
stuff and we meaning crowdsource studios
in the screenplay competition it's going
to be me and other professional
screenwriters are going to judge where
the judges essentially we're the judges
for the finalists we will pick five
finalists based on story parts for
actors budget commercial viability stuff
like that and we will choose five
finalists each finalist has a page a
dedicated page on our website with their
bio including their social networking
handle and stuff like that
a bit of info about their script the
title the genre the logline and most
importantly a video they're going to
upload a video under five minutes of
them the writer pitching their script
just like they're gonna have to do in a
Hollywood room they have to pitch it and
they show sorry they show the video
themselves yeah just you know just can
be on your computer or whatever just any
sort of yep absolutely and then our
members crowdsource studios members will
vote for their favorite script most
favorite pitch whatever it's based on
and so at that point we have a script
and if by the way if anybody wants to
enter its its if you go to our website
you'll see it but it's it's crowdsource
studios com and we will figure it out so
um there is an entry fee sorry yeah
grace there's an early bird and there's
a regular and there's a late deadline
and we may extend it and all that kind
of stuff but it's reasonably price it's
it's less than the average contest I
think the early bird is twenty bucks so
then we have a script and at that point
we say I'm going to at that point we say
directors send same thing send us your
real send us your stuff we submit to us
your your reels will do the same thing
professional directors will judge the
directors on trees yep and each finalist
will pick five finalists based on their
reels generally period aunt or comma and
then each director will have a page on
our website with their bio their reals
we will provide the finalists with a
copy of the script and they will upload
a five minute or so pitch of their
vision for the film and our members
it'll probably have about a month or so
to decide or to vote and then we'll have
a director and we do the same thing with
actors probably simultaneously with
directors will do the same thing with
actors we have a part for a 32 year old
woman in a 38 year old man send us your
reels actors
we will meaning professional actors
probably producers probably directors
and some screenwriters too will judge
the actors realz will pick five each one
puts up will have their real and they'll
each put up an audition they'll pick
whatever so we'll give them this copy of
the script they'll pick a scene or two
and the whole audition and our members
vote for the winners and then we have
the principal elements in place
you